yeah i mean i just finished uh bob iger
oh ride of a lifetime and fantastic
just really to chapter after chapter i
mean it's like every chapter could have
made a career
and he just you know and he strings six
of them together and to just
appreciate sort of you know what he
accomplished and i mean with
um with chad's passing um black panther
i mean i remember
bob iger in the book just talking about
as an organization
sort of being presented the case that a
black superhero was not going to perform
well in
making the decision and the conviction
to do it all the same
yeah and you know it is the most like
tweet i think you know nearly
universally admired and respected one of
just the the great imprints of
of sort of you know in in culture and in
um you know the conversation inside the
last you know five ten years and
and you know it's really fun reading
reading sort of that moment and
and leadership was there something you
took away from bob bogger's ride of
lifetime bob bugger hasn't been on the
pod yet but
open invite if anybody knows him uh i
want to zoom in with him
incredible book we used we did that in
our book club actually
what was your takeaway from his
experience being an entrepreneur
who starts things versus bob iger who is
entrepreneurial inside of other people's
companies
yeah i mean um intrapreneurship
often feels like uh
you know you're cheating somehow i mean
it's so hard starting
these companies and and to be surrounded
by the the safety net and infrastructure
and resources of big companies i mean
just
to me it never feels the same and yet
you know leading
disney is different than building
something from the ground up and it was
an
experience that that equipped him and
prepared him
for the challenges of leading you know a
multinational global organization
with properties across a lot of you know
not just media but i mean running cruise
ships and and in
entertainment and um you know it
prepared him well and i think you know
all of us as we look at our careers
should be clear in what we're trying to
accomplish you know because the
the pathway um that will most
successfully lead you there is is
different for every one of us yeah i
i always had the same thing with you
like there's no comparison between
starting and working you know and then
you read bob iger's book and you realize
well he had to navigate all that
politics
and all of the strategy
that was being uh pushed on him and i
think the big revelation for me was that
the bigger the strategy department under
michael eisner got the more they were
suffocating the units
and that the streamlining of that and
that what got you here does not get you
there like michael eisner was
dead set against the pixar acquisition
and
you know iger just saw clearly that that
was
just absolutely had to occur
and he had the ability to talk to steve
jobs and he learned
some kind of i don't know if it's he i
i get a great sense of humility from him
which i think works when you're dealing
with someone like steve jobs when you
come in
you know and say you know like steve
jobs would if you're battling with him
like bill gates did it's going to be
down to you know they're going to those
are gladiators right whereas
you know when he came into steve jobs he
was like i think we should talk
but uh you know i'd love to open that
dialogue with you if that's possible
and you know he's like on pins and
needles waiting to see steve jobs
yeah let's talk right now like tonight
right now and then like in the driveway
talking to steve jobs
about trying to close the deal where if
it had been michael eisner
like that paradigm just would not have
worked michael eisner
and steve jobs equals no deal but bob
is uh you know he was in it he was
becoming the steward of a legacy
and i think it was that you know sort of
sensibility that that resonated with
you know with marvel with with pixar
with uh
you know with all of it yeah when he
talks about the marvel deal too and
getting who's that guy kevin
uh feige kevin feige getting him on
board
and then talking with george lucas and
getting him on board
it feels to me like bob iger was the
only executive
who could have done that like just that
ability to talk with that
those that level of personality yeah and
be able to close the deal with them and
listen to them and have empathy it's
just something that
the other side of the table doesn't have
right like what gets you what made steve
jobs and george lucas
steve jobs and george lucas is not what
made bob agar bob iger
right it's like it's almost like this
yin yang kind of thing